I'm also working on my new book quite a lot actually.
Um,
it's tentatively titled Beyond Order 12 more rules for life or perhaps beyond
mere order.
I haven't decided on that yet.
Um,
I can tell you what the rules are.
Maybe you'd be interested in that.
So I'll give you a list of them.
The first one is do not carelessly denigrate social institutions or creative
achievement
rule to imagine who you could be.
And then aim singlemindedly at that
rule three.
Work as hard as you can.
Work as hard as you possibly can on at least one thing and see what happens.
Rule four,
do not hide unwanted things in the fog.
Rule five,
abandoned ediology abandoned ideology rules six,
notice that opportunity lurks where responsibility has been abdicated.
Rule seven,
do not do things that you hate.
Rural.
Eight,
try to make one room in your house as beautiful as possible.
Rule Nine,
if old memories still make you cry,
right them down carefully and completely
rural 10 plan and work diligently to maintain the romance in your relationship.
Rule 11,
be grateful in spite of your suffering.
And then rule 12,
do not allow yourself to become resentful,
deceitful,
or arrogant.
In principle,
that book will be published in January,
2020 so,
and I'm supposed to have the manuscript in sometime within the next six months
and I have a first draft done and I'm working hard on the repeated edits.
Um,
it's going to be published simultaneously in the UK and the U S and Canada.
I'm working with three different editors and so that's that part of the
announcement.
So I'm hoping,
I'm really hoping that I can make the next book better.
I think it would be a pair,
you'll be a parent coffee with the first one.
I'm probably going to publish it with a black cover to go with the white cover
of 12 rules,
and I'm hoping that I can make it into a better book and that the two together
will make a very complete set.